qui est cette nouvelle idole de la
chanson une tragédienne alice sapritch a
enregistré son premier disque s'intitule
sa priest à nu les hommes sont des
poupées
quand je les déshabillent te trouves
congestionné dans mes bras de pilleurs
comme je suis comédienne quand on m'a
apporté une chanson je voulais
interprété la chanson mais hélas
voyez là il y a une chose terrible des
notes beaucoup de difficultés parce que
vous avez pu le constater il a fallu
reprendre des cours de chant il a fallu
sélectionner les choses sont fonction de
sa tessiture vocale et puis il a fallu
aussi lui apprendre à chanter non
seulement tout passer sa voix mais dans
un studio
alors ça a été très dur
les vocalises hubert organise une série
à a
ça va ça le plaisir de la chair le désir
de la plaine ont peur de ce thriller
fouet qui subsistent et je faire vous
avez plutôt chanter déco trianon je n'ai
pas chanté que des gaudriole j'ai chanté
les deux c'est à dire des choses
amusantes des choses dramatiques mais je
suis france pour me connaissez depuis
quelques temps je suis ce personnage à
la fois un drôle dramatique triste
désespéré je suis comme la nuit allongés
dans le déshonneur pour vous deux mois
trois années de conservatoire pour en
faire du cochon l'horreur
c'est dans la - 0
ceylan midas 1000 m
combien d'heures faut-il pour faire un
disque comme ça celui là de plus de 100
c'est à dire à peu près cinq fois plus
que pour les autres artistes qui sont
déjà dans le métier de la chanson
regardez là vous voyez comme s'il
entrait ici pour la première fois
c'était un soir où johnny enregistrés et
j'ai vu mon nom à côté de johnny côté de
sardou à côté de sylvie vartan et ça ça
m'impressionne toujours un peu je vais
te fais ma voix je veux je veux parce
que je veux chanter des choses très
dures
je veux chanter des sur des rythmes sûr
surtout ça quand même pas l'air desclaux
chaque no no no no justement c'est le
contraire que je veux faire je me perds
deschamps sauvage
smig à m
malouda